arizona's department of education now
links to chat rooms on its website for
young people who are identifying as
lgbtq
lmnop plus
to discuss sex and gender
with adult moderators
without their parents knowing
the ade
directed minors to cue chat space and
gender spectrum
those organizations rely on adult
volunteers and staff to facilitate the
minors talking about sex in these chat
rooms without their parents knowledge
there is no age verification for those
joining the chats beyond just asking the
people for a birth date
we reached out at the daily wire we
reached out to the arizona department of
education about these chat rooms uh no
one has responded to our inquiry the
online chat is so insidious it has a
quick escape function so the arizona
department of education just like old
man herbert and family guy just like
that the creepy neighbor down the street
who's leering at the kids they say hey
come on here are you are you questioning
sexuality young people under the age of
18. well come into our chat rooms yes
they're run by
adult volunteers
and
by the way we don't verify anybody's age
in here young people yes come on in and
by the way if your mean old nasty
parents have a look at you there's a
quick escape button
so if daddy walks into the room and you
don't want them know that we the
government are using his taxpayer
dollars to encourage you to talk about
sex with creepy weird adults strangers
just click that quick escape button
and then it'll disappear daddy will
never see the minute he walks by then
you can come back and talk about sex
with us adults paid for on the taxpayer
time do you think this is a good idea
i don't think it's a good idea
you know what it sounds like to me it
sounds like
they're kind of
groomers
you remember a few weeks ago there's
this big controversy how dare you call
the teachers pushing gender theory in
schools groomers that's so unfair that's
what you heard from the left and that's
what you heard from the squishy right
that's unfair that's undignified don't
call them that
no no
and you say well it seems like kind of a
slippery slope it seems like a kind of
an easily abused situation if a teacher
is talking about sex to five and
six-year-olds no no that's wrong we'll
never slip down the slippery slow
boom here we are and now we've got the
arizona government encouraging creepy
weirdo adults to talk about sex to kids
without the kids knowing without the
kid's parents knowing
no i'm i think i'm at the bottom of the
slippery slope but
deep down i know i'm not
i know we're not we keep thinking we've
hit the bottom and we're going to slide
so much further aren't we and when when
i say that right now the liberals are
going to say michael you're crazy you're
a conspiracy theorist no no it's not
going to get any worse well i don't
we've been slipping pretty fast pretty
far for a long time now
we're already at the stage of
taxpayer-subsidized
pervert adults talking to little kids
about sex on government linked websites
how much further can we go this is why
it's so important for
our legislatures to step up
not the administrative agencies which
are almost entirely unaccountable to the
will of voters voters who are generally
a lot more normal
and a lot more closer to the common
sense than these government bureaucrats
we need to assert our political vision
and our reason and our logic and our our
will through the legislature that's what
indiana just did
so the indiana legislature run by the
republicans
proposed a bill
to ban dudes who pretend to be girls
from competing in girls sports
really basic stuff and we've seen this
throughout the country in lots of
different states
and unfortunately the governor of
indiana eric holcomb vetoed the bill
maybe governor holcomb had his reasons i
like eric holcomb personally actually
i've known eric holcomb for years and i
like him personally i don't know what he
was thinking here he was in the wrong to
veto this bill
so what did the legislature do did they
did they throw up their hands and say
okay
that's that never mind no they overrode
his veto so
holcomb's argument was in the two cases
with initial rulings thus far far the
courts have enjoined or prohibited laws
with the same substantive provisions
from taking effect based on equal
protection grounds
okay so that's just a way of saying i
think the courts are going to strike
down this law because the courts are
going to try to trans the kids then he
also said there was a third concern
which is that the newly proposed law
implies that the goals of consistency
and fairness in competitive female
sports are not currently being met but
after thorough review i find no evidence
to support either claim even if i
support the overall goal now this
this last part is crazy even if even if
he might have a practical political
point on the first part that the courts
could strike it down again i'm not i
wouldn't bet on that i would i would
still certainly sign the law even if
that were my main concern but this this
last point here is crazy he's saying
look there's no evidence that female
sports are are unfair right now
look at the ncaa women's swimming
championship who won the prize you've
got a giant hulking dude
with all of his giant hulking dude parts
pretty clearly visible in his silly
women's bathing suit that he was wearing
he's got
the gold medal he's got prize number one
and then you've got these diminutive
little girls next to him
they're obviously different they're
obviously at a disadvantage
so this seems to be just a complete
denial of of reality regardless i'm not
i don't know whatever whatever the
thinking was in the governor's office
this is the right thing to do for the
legislature to go in and say look you're
our governor you're our governor and we
love you but you're wrong on this issue
and we're going to override you
absolutely the right thing to do and
that's what what conservatives should be
doing around the country when they meet
pushback whether it's because
the republicans are getting too many
calls from worried corporations whether
it's because the governors
are trying to find a middle ground on
this issue of our boys boys or our boys
girls no middle ground to have
whatever the reason
republicans need to stand up and push
back
this will be a political winner i
promise you i promise you it's not just
the right thing to do it's a political
winner i'm glad you liked that clip now
stop ring the bell link click subscribe
smash do whatever you have to do get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
leave a 75 star review for the michael
knowles show we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you